with you all we're in a very critical
phase of our war against the coronavirus
it's vital that every American follows
our guidelines on the 30 days to slow
the spread the sacrifices we make over
the next four weeks will have countless
American lives saved we're going to save
a lot of American lives and we're in
control of our own fate very much so
maintaining social distance practicing
vigorous hygiene and staying at home are
your most effective ways to win the war
and to escape danger while you're
fighting this battle from home we're
working with the best scientists doctors
and researchers anywhere in the world
we're racing to develop new ways to
protect against the virus as well as
therapies treatments and ultimately a
vaccine and we're making a lot of
progress
I think medically a lot of progress at
the same time we're also racing to get
relief to American workers and small
businesses as you know I want to remind
small-business owners across America
that the Paycheck protection program is
launching tomorrow nearly three hundred
and fifty billion dollars in loans will
be available to small businesses
including sole proprietors these loans
are up to 100 percent forgivable as long
as employers keep paying their workers
gotta take care of your workers
furthermore we want Social Security
beneficiaries to know that if they are
typically not required to file a tax
return they don't have to file one in
order to receive the direct cash
payments that will soon be distributed
to American citizens the Treasury will
deposit the money directly into the bank
accounts and don't forget I will always
protect your Social Security your
Medicare and your Medicaid we're
protecting Social Security Medicare and
Medicaid and I always will
I'd like now to invite SBA administrator
Jovita Carranza is doing a fantastic job
she's going to be very busy in the next
little while and secretary Steve
Nutan to say a few words about these
vital initiatives and then we'll get on
to the attack of the virus itself and
please if I might stave in Jovita thank
you
Thank You mr. president and mr. vice
president secretary Ellucian Ivanka
Trump and all who I have been working
closely with in this effort small
business is the backbone of the American
economy and the president has put the
nation's 30 million small businesses
front and center in the response effort
and we are working hard to get money to
them quickly this is an unprecedented
effort by this administration to support
small businesses and we know that there
will be challenges in the process
secretary minuchin and I are working in
tandem to ensure that feedback from our
partners is being heard and implemented
the private and public sector must work
closely together to ensure that small
businesses and their workers across the
country are put first this
administration believes wholeheartedly
that if you are a small business you are
a critical part of the economic fabric
of this country and your viability is
critical to the economic well-being of
your employees at SBA we are working
around the clock to support small
businesses ensuring that we are
prioritizing emergency capital for small
businesses that are suffering economic
harm as a result of this unprecedented
situation this relief will help
stabilize a small business sector by
providing businesses with the financial
resources they need to keep their
workers employed and keep up with their
day-to-day operating expenses today I
want to ensure that small businesses all
over the country know about the Paycheck
protection program and how they can
benefit from this simply put the
Paycheck protection program is to help
keep employees on payroll and small
businesses open
s.p.a will forgive the portion of the
loan that is used toward job retention
and certain other expenses we are
working closely with lenders so that
businesses can go directly to their
local lenders paycheck protection
program is in addition to substantial
work that the SBA has and will continue
to do to help small businesses including
providing advances on SBA disaster loans
and forgiving existing SBA loan payments
over the next six months additional
details on these critically important
programs can be found at sba.gov
and we will be updating these resources
regularly our hearts go out to those
affected by this terrible virus our
communities around the country are
stepping up and we will get through this
together at SBA we know that every phone
call email or application submitted has
a small business owner their employees
and the communities they support around
the other side our most important
objective is to allow small businesses
to keep their employees on board and
keep their businesses viable through
this unprecedented disruption I want to
reiterate the importance of patience in
this process as we work together to
ensure that businesses are able to
access needed credit we will continue
working around the clock as we've done
with our federal and private sector
partners expanding capacity and working
to make our systems as robust as
possible to meet the needs Thank You mr.
president
Thank You mr. president Thank You mr.
vice president thank you to Evita mr.
president you've made clear to us we now
need to execute we need to get money to
small business and American workers and
that's what we're doing the SBA and
Treasury committed to get this program
up and running tomorrow and when Jovita
says people working around the clock
they literally we had both teams working
til four o'clock in the morning and
start working again today we've heard
feedback from lenders community banks
regional bank
and we spent the last 24 hours making
this system even easier so this will be
up and running tomorrow I encourage all
small businesses that have 500 or fewer
people please contact your lenders and
the FDIC institution will be able to do
this any credit union existing SBA
lenders and FinTech lenders you get the
money
you'll get it the same day you use this
to pay your workers please bring your
workers back to work if you let them go
you have 8 weeks plus overhead this is a
very important program I'm pleased to
announce we are going to raise the
interest rate on these loans and again
the interest rate is paid for as part of
the program the bar doesn't have to pay
this to 1% we had announced it was going
to be 50 basis points we've heard from
some smaller community banks that their
deposit costs even though the
government's borrowing at three or four
basis points this is on average a 90-day
loan to make this attractive for
community banks we've agreed to raise
the interest rate again I encourage
everybody take out the Paycheck
protection program I'm also pleased to
report the economic impact payments I
had previously said this would take us
three weeks I'm pleased to report that
within two weeks the first payments will
be direct deposit into taxpayers account
and as the president said last night the
president authorized me to say that
anybody that has Social Security
recipients won't need to file a new tax
return and we'll have that if we don't
have your direct deposit information
we'll be putting up a web portal so that
you can put that up it is a very large
priority the president has made clear we
want to get this money quickly into your
hands I'm also pleased to report that we
continue to work closely with the
Federal Reserve we're in the process of
designing a new facility that we call
the Main Street lending facility we're
also looking at facilities for state
governments as well and I'm also pleased
to report the employee retention credit
it's up and running the first $10,000 of
wages you get a 50% credit that's 5,000
dollars per person and for everyone
who's kept someone you can immediately
get that money you can deduct it from
what you owe the IRS immediately if you
don't owe us money you'll get a
refundable tax credit so that is up and
running I'm also pleased to report we
have the program up and running we're
taking applications from the airlines
from the cargo companies and from
national security companies so thank you
very much mr. president mr. secretary a
Chase Bank sent a letter to its business
clients today saying they don't have
necessary guidance from the SBA from the
Treasury Department be able to accept
the loan applications starting tomorrow
the need is clearly enormous but at
least one major bank says they're not
fully empowered yet to be able to help
there I spoke to all the CEOs yesterday
I had a conference call with them we got
very good input from them on what they
needed as I said people were working
till four o'clock I believe we just put
up the Federal Register with the new
guidelines for lenders I've been assured
that the banks will be in the process
starting tomorrow now again it's going
to take a little bit of time but we
committed that this will be available
tomorrow and I encourage all companies
go to s be a calm go to Treasury gov you
can see the information you need
immediately and there's a tremendous
power struggle going on between the
Treasury and SBA and that it's over
processing forms is what they tell me
that lenders are actually opting out
because they can't make enough money to
even service the loans so how are you
going to make sure these small business
owners get the capital they need to
survive right now first of all I can
assure you jovi it is here Jovita used
to work for me as the treasurer there's
no power struggle Jovita and our team as
I said worked together till four o'clock
in the morning started working at seven
o'clock again we've made the form
simpler and I can assure you at five
points I've told these bankers they
should take all their traders and put
them in the branches so it'll never be
another opportunity to earn five points
on a 90 day government fully government
guaranteed loan
checks right into direct deposit IRS now
saying take four to five months you're
saying two weeks let me be clear I don't
know let me be clear I don't know where
you're hearing these things I told you
this would be three weeks I'm now
committing to two weeks we're delivering
on our commitments the IRS which I
oversee within two weeks the first money
won't be in people's deposits ound like
those will go up pretty quickly the
question is then folks who don't have
direct deposit and there was a statute
oh well there were released by the House
Ways and Means Committee today saying
that that process could take up to five
weeks that takes you to mid-august is
that how long that is not gonna let me
just say when Obama sent out these
checks it took months and months and
months I am assuring the American public
they need the money now what we're gonna
do is again if we have your information
you'll get it into in within two weeks
Social Security you'll get it very
quickly after that if we don't have your
information you'll have a simple web
portal you'll upload it if we don't have
that we'll send your checks in the mail
process a lot of checks but we don't
want to send checks in this environment
we don't want people to get checks we
want to put money directly into their
account this is for I guess both you and
the administrator there been some
anecdotal reports that business people
trying to get access to the online site
to submit the applications the websites
been crashing I've heard of webinars
going offline because there's just too
many people on them so how you guys
gonna be ready you know tomorrow to get
these loans out we've brought in a lot
of external resources at SBA and us to
make sure there's additional capacity as
I said we heard a lot of good feedback
yesterday to simplify this process it's
gonna be up and running now let me just
be clear that doesn't mean everybody is
going to get their loan tomorrow but the
system will be up and running we
encourage people over the next week sign
up you can go on right now you can go on
the web see what information you need
very simple process
Ariana's separate subject have you been
in touch with leader McConnell and
speaker Pelosi about their differences
right now about another stimulus package
I spoke I've spoken to the leader I
spoken to the speaker I've spoken to the
president constantly when the president
is ready and thinks we should do the
next stage we're ready the president's
talked about the issue of infrastructure
since the campaign I think you know
that's a big priority for him and again
if we run out of money on the small
business program we'll be back right
away to Congress to get this increased
well let me just say you know we're
going through something that we've never
done before where the government has
shut down big parts of the economy
because of health reasons our economy
was in great shape our companies were in
great shape there are three ways that
Americans are going to be protected for
small business they'll get paid by their
business through this program the direct
deposit there's also enhanced
unemployment so we realized
unfortunately there are a lot of
companies that because they aren't in
business over a short period of time
again we're working with the states on
enhanced unemployment and as soon as the
medical professionals and the president
give the all-clear we're gonna have a
ton of liquidity we have about six
trillion dollars this has never been
done between us and the Fed to put into
the economy to support American workers
in American business in addition to the
jobless numbers we saw today these three
was signed before the social distancing
guidelines were extended for another
month
so what additional relief are you gonna
give to Americans as they
day out of work for all these extra
weeks and what are you waiting for
well we in designing this program we
thought that we had liquidity for about
ten weeks and and that's what we've
designed and again I think the
president's been very clear if we need
to go back to Congress to support the
American economy and American workers we
will be doing that mr. secretary
secretary Duchenne has become antsy
Pelosi has formed a select committee to
oversee the distribution of recovery
funds and she says she wants to make
sure that those funds are wisely and
efficiently spent do you think that
Select Committee is something that's
necessary
i I don't I mean you know the both both
parties wanted us to have oversight
wanted us to have transparency we have
full transparency we have a Oversight
Committee that the speaker gets to pick
someone the leader gets to pick someone
I believe there's five people on it and
again that that committee will review
the money that we're spending and again
we support full transparency taxpayers
should understand how we're going to
support this economy and jobs secretary
the second senator Murkowski has asked
you to consider providing loans to
energy companies under the cares Act the
phase three bill what are your thoughts
on that would you consider providing
those loans to energy companies so thank
you and let me clarify I have very
limited ability to do direct loans out
of the Treasury I can do them for
passenger airlines cargo airlines
contractors and national security
companies outside of that we work with
the Federal Reserve to create
broad-based lending facilities which we
will do so our expectation is the energy
companies like all our other companies
will be able to participate in
broad-based facilities whether it's the
corporate facility or whether it's the
Main Street facility but not direct
lending out of the Treasury
so Americans for those folks who don't
have bank accounts who don't have direct
deposit information on file with the IRS
how long would they have to wait for
their tech well for people who don't
have direct deposit again we'll have an
easy way they put it up we can on a
rolling basis I think you know within a
couple of days when they give it to us
we'll send the money out we do realize
there are people who are under banked
and again we're working with all the
digital companies prepaid debit cards
we're working with all of them to make
sure we have a process that every
American gets their money quickly this
money does people know good if it shows
up in four months and we will deliver on
that promise leave as a matter of weeks
then perhaps not months quickly as a
matter of weeks and not months that's
correct where you can make direct loans
it's the airlines how much do you expect
that the Treasury Department in the
federal government will be involved in
overseeing the operations of airlines as
it pertains to which routes get cut back
how much they operate what they do about
their employees and the like so there
there are very strict requirements
that's built into the bill again this
was a bipartisan requirement one
anything we do with the airlines they
have to maintain substantially all of
their employees so again any money that
we provide them will go to pay their
employees we're going to be working with
the Secretary of Transportation there
are requirements to maintain certain
routes so again we have a very clear
process we've hired three outside
advisors will be financial advisors and
three law firms will be releasing that
information shortly and I want to thank
them they're all working for basically
very very little money they couldn't
work for free so they've agreed to
basically work for what they would sign
up to work for charitable organizations
so again no big fees to bankers we got a
great team of three lawyers and three
financial advisors that will assist us
the names of those people who are
advising you when you release the
information first we will give you the
names as well as the the contracts so
again right now so again I'm happy to
announce it we have PG at the pjt
partners okay is going to do the
passenger airlines Mullis and company is
going to do the cargo and contractors
and Perella Weinberg will handle the
national security and there'll be three
law firms which will announce shortly
that will be working in each one of
those sectors and again let me just be
clear we need to get this done quickly
the airlines need money we're gonna work
very closely with the Department of
Transportation and get this done quickly
we've actually already received
contracts from a lot of the people again
there's guidance up on the web full
transparency we've asked for
applications on the airline issue again
speaker Pelosi and others have said that
the government taking stakes in those
airline should not be a condition for
the federal government to provide
payroll support specifically what's your
response to that I spoke to the speaker
last night about that this was something
that was highly negotiated between the
Republicans and the Democrats the
president was personally involved in
this he was on the phone with us many
times Mitch McConnell mark meadows
senators on both sides there is a
specific line in the bill that says that
the secretary meaning me will determine
proper compensation so this is not a
bailout for the airlines and I will be
working once we get our advice from our
financial advisors we get the
applications from the airlines I'll be
working very closely with the president
and will make sure that we strike the
right balance not a bailout taxpayers
get compensated but the these airlines
these are national security issues we
want to keep our Airlines in tack
the administrator is not for you as well
some small businesses restaurant orders
owners for example are finding that
laying off their employees so that they
can start collecting unemployment it's
better both for them as business owners
and for their workers what incentives do
they have right now to keep their
employees on the payroll if no one's
coming into their restaurant
well the incentive that you have and we
want American business to be kept intact
the incentive is these are loans that
turn into grants so if you're a business
owner and you're a restaurant you can
hire your people back you get money for
their their medical you keep them on the
medical plan you get money for your rent
you get money for your electricity so
you're motivated we want you to have a
business that you can reopen quickly
when it's appropriate so this doesn't
cost the business owners anything you
know when people talk about I can't
imagine any American worker who had a
job is offered to keep their job it
isn't gonna want to have it and let me
just be clear we've also talked about
this unemployment issue you can only get
unemployment if you don't have a job so
unemployment is intended for those
people that are some of the midsize or
larger businesses and we're very
sympathetic to this that these companies
can't afford and for those people the
Enhanced unemployment will be a
significant benefit but we want to make
sure 50% of the American workforce is
small businesses under five hundred
people the president the vice president
the administrator and I want to make
sure this part of the economy is ready
and intact when we're ready to reopen is
there a certain category of small
businesses that you're most concerned
about restaurants hair salons things
that's a great question we're concerned
about every small business there's 30
million small businesses that were
really focused on and we're working
feverishly to make sure that we can
provide the available funds to them as
quickly as possible so it's 30 million
small businesses and the other
businesses are being dealt with with the
PPP but the Paycheck protection there
was also the disaster what we call it
the injury or economic injury disaster
loan and then there was an advanced
associated with that particular program
as well so to answer your question we're
concerned about all businesses and as
the secretary indicated we're looking at
employees being ready not lost in this
process where what we want businesses to
stay intact because they represent half
the half the GDP so if we spend a
trillion to support 10 trillion or 11
trillion I think that's a significant
investment and that's what we're focused
on one comment for explanation because I
want to make sure everybody out there
understands this if you're an
independent contractor if you're a sole
proprietor you're eligible for this as
well now that program won't be up and
running until next week but again this
is a very broad definition of small
business so if you're an independent
plumber if you're an independent
contractor you're covered under this
program slightly more complicated you
have to come in to your bank and give
them more information but starting next
week that part of the program will be up
and running also charities charities as
well very important the vice president
and president makes sure that we covered
small charities in this
it does although there are some
technical issues but yes it does include
faith organizations this is under the
the PPP yes the new SBA program they are
covered thank you okay so that begins
right away and they start handing out
checks a lot of people are gonna have
their businesses built back up quickly I
hope and we'll see it complicated big
small business is actually big business
so I thank them both and please we have
some great gentlemen let me say
gentlemen that's correct
thank you very much today my
administration is also issuing new
guidelines to protect elderly Americans
who remain the most vulnerable by now
nursing homes should have suspended the
entry of all medically unnecessary
personnel today we're further
recommending that all nursing home
facilities decide the same staff to care
for the same group of residents
consistently to minimize any potential
spread and we're also urging facilities
to designate separate areas for healthy
and sick residents and this is a
practice that we probably will be
recommending into the future long after
the enemy is gone this particular enemy
is God we're also making every effort to
provide relief to our great veterans we
take very good care of our veterans at
my direction secretary Wilkie will use
any authority at his disposal to extend
deadlines for benefits and to postpone
debt collections we're now conducting
well over 100,000 corona virus tests per
day it's over a hundred thousand tests a
day and these are accurate tests and
they're moving rapidly which is more
than any other country in the world both
in terms of the raw number and also on a
per capita basis the most the FDA is
also authorized to fir
coronavirus antibody test developed
about selects a key step that will help
identify people who have recovered and
to understand their immune response and
their immune system
moments ago I directed secretary a czar
an acting secretary wolf to use any and
all available authority under the
defense production act to ensure that
domestic manufacturers have the supplies
they need to produce ventilators for
patients with severe cases of Co VI D 19
you know what that is right
become a very famous term Co VI D kovat
this action will help General Electric
Hill ROM Medtronic ResMed Royal Philips
and by air medical overcome obstacles in
the supply chain that threatened the
rapid production of ventilators we have
over a hundred thousand being built
right now or soon to be started
we anticipate issuing more orders under
the defense production act in the very
near future in addition to the one that
I've just signed against 3m for face
masks we assigned a element of the act
against 3m and hopefully they'll be able
to do what they are supposed to do just
spoke to Mary Berra of General Motors
and she said they're very soon going to
be ready to start production of the
ventilators they have a lot of
ventilators that they've committed to
built and they'll be starting very very
quickly FEMA continues to deliver
resources to areas most affected by the
virus including New York on top of the
3,000 beds were already providing to the
Javits Center the Department of Defense
is adding another 48 ICU beds Governor
Cuomo has asked that this facility go
and it's a big beautiful facility it be
converted to a kovat hospital and we
hadn't done that yet we hadn't thought
in terms of doing that but their uses
they're real
demand is for that and we had meetings
on it with the task force we had
meetings with the military and I've
decided to say yes I'm going to do that
that I will be signing and agreeing to a
yes answer so that we will be doing that
and also we will be staffing it so the
federal government is doing a lot of
things that wasn't anticipated that it
do this is a 2500 and or 2900 can easily
be set up hospital built in Javits
Center and so we're going to be
converting that to a covet 19 hospital
and it's going to be staffed by the
military and by the federal government
and based on the fact that I agreed to
that we had two other facilities that
were likewise asking for it and that
would be in Louisiana and also in Dallas
and we'll be doing those we spoke to the
governor of Louisiana spoke to the
governor of Texas and we've told them
that we will be staffing those hospitals
again above and beyond but that's okay
we have to do that in addition the u.s.
NS comfort is docked in New York to
accept patients that is a non Kovac to
date FEMA has delivered more than 4
million n95 mask respirators and it's
think of that 4 million 4 million don't
forget we're a secondary source the
states are doing it and we're backing
them up but we've gotten four million
n95 respirators 1.8 million surgical
masks 460 thousand face shields 1.4
million gloves and four thousand four
hundred ventilators just to the city and
to the state of New York and some of
them now are being sent I spoke with
both Governor Cuomo and mayor de Blasio
a little while ago and some of them are
being sent to the city all of America
stands with the people of New York in
this time of
it's definitely a hotspot but we have
other hotspots also and we're taking
them taking care of them very very
strongly very powerfully we have the
finest people in the world in those
locations and I think the federal
government has not only acted early but
acted quickly professionally there's no
people like this doctors nurses first
responders and other health care
providers who want to help New York at
this critical time should visit website
nyc.gov slash help now nyc.gov slash
help now
they need help now they need people to
help them we have great facilities and
we've built some brand new facilities
big ones but we need help we need help
for professional people so if you're in
an area that isn't so affected and
you're a doctor a nurse a healthcare
worker please get to that website and we
would really appreciate your help New
York City needs it Louisiana by the way
needs it Michigan needs it whatever you
can do those are very strong hot spots
they need help in recent weeks as the
virus has spread and economic hardship
has followed we have seen Americans
unite with incredible selflessness and
compassion I want to remind everyone
here in our nation's capitol especially
in Congress that this is not the time
for politics endless partisan
investigations here we go again I've
already done extraordinary damage to our
country in recent years you see what
happens it's witch hunt after witch hunt
after witch hunt and in the end the
people doing the witch hunt have been
losing and they've been losing by a lot
and it's not any time for witch hunts
it's time to get this enemy defeated
conducting these partisan investigations
in the middle of a pandemic is a really
big waste of vital resources time
attention and we want to fight for
American lives not waste time and build
up my poll numbers because that's all
they're doing because everyone knows
it's ridiculous
so we want to focus on the people of
this country even the people of the
world we're going to be able to help
them because right now is an example
we're building so many ventilators very
very hard to build but we're building
thousands thousands of them and a lot of
them will be coming at a time where we
won't need them as badly because it
takes time very complex we're expensive
and we'll be able to help outside of our
country we think we'll be able to help
that's something that you cannot easily
produce as citizens were linked together
by the shared bonds of national love
loyalty and affection there's no earthly
force more powerful than the patriotic
pride that stirs in our hearts and that
is so true
it's incredible the job that everybody's
been doing everybody they don't sleep
they don't go to bed sometimes they get
nothing said to somebody recently on the
task force how many hours sleep have you
gotten over the last couple of days the
answer was none none in one
Massachusetts neighborhood citizens come
out of their homes each night at eight
o'clock from their porches and they sing
god bless america
others have joined in spreading from
house to house down one Street up to the
next until their little town with a
spirit of patriotism and reminding all
Americans that were all in this together
we'll fight together and we will win
together we're gonna win this now what
I'd like to do is I'm going to step out
we have a meeting on the subject and I'm
gonna step out just for a few moments
I'll be right back we'll answer some
questions but you have some very
hardworking people who have done an
incredible job led by Vice President
Mike Pence head of the task force and
then Jared Kushner is going to say a few
words and Admiral full of check Peter
Navarro dr. Burks and myself I'll be
right back so I'll see you in a little
while I did take a test we just came out
this is from the White House physician
you may have it just came out I just
took it this morning and I took it it
took me literally a minute to take it
and it took me I guess it was 14 or 15
minutes
I went to work I didn't wait for it but
said it took 14 minutes or something to
come up with the conclusion and it said
the president tested negative for covet
19 so that's the second one I think I
took it really out of curiosity to see
how quickly it worked and fast at work
and it's a lot easier I've done them
both and the second one is much more
pleasant Jeff I can tell you that much
more pleasant so I'll be back in a
little while and Mike please take over
thank you thank you all very much I'll
be right back Thank You mr. president
the White House coronavirus task force
met today but earlier in the day the
president convened all the key elements
of our supply chain team in the Oval
Office for an update on the progress
that we've been making working literally
around the clock to make sure that our
health care workers the people on the
front lines have the personal protective
equipment and also the ventilators to be
able to meet this moment and today
you're going to hear from the people
that are literally working working each
and every day to make that happen dr.
deborah birx is also with us to shield
reflect in a few moments on the progress
that that we're making analyzing the
data each and every day we're looking
county by county state by state
consulting with with governors and local
health officials at the present moment
more than 1.3 million tests have been
performed and as you all are aware some
236 thousand Americans have tested
positive for the corona virus with now
the losses over 5,000 Americans and our
hearts are with their families beyond
that we have been focusing not just on
ensuring the testing is occurring but
that the supplies are flowing as the
president just announced he made a
decision today to deploy thousands of
n95 masks directly to New York City's
public hospitals and our team will speak
about that in just a moment and also the
president took the
in step to direct the Department of
Defense to use military health care
personnel to operate all covin
facilities at the Javits Center in New
York at the Convention Center in New
Orleans and at the Convention Center in
Dallas and we've informed each of the
governors of those states today that
their requests we were making those
military medical personnel available to
operate in all Kovac facility but we
would emphasize to people in that
community who believe you've been
impacted or contracted to coronavirus
contact your local health care provider
we anticipate in the New York area that
your local health care provider will
make the decision whether you are
transferred to the Javits Center and in
all cases simply look to the guidance of
your local governor's about how best to
receive the care that every American
every American is entitled to have
beyond that let me say that we have been
working through FEMA's acquisition
process not only to deploy but to to
gather up personal protective equipment
and in just a few moments you will hear
from Admiral John Paul of check about
the extraordinary progress that we have
made in deploying not just the strategic
national stockpile but also in
identifying on the commercial
marketplace around America and around
the world literally millions of n95
masks
surgical gowns gloves protective
equipment and at this point we've
distributed as some 7600 ventilators and
you'll hear today specifically about the
states that have received those
ventilators we're just this team is
truly acted in an inspiring way and
literally is is working with dozens and
dozens of people at the at the FEMA
stabilization task force to make sure
that we are leaving no stone unturned to
find the supplies we need let me also
say today you're going to hear from
Jared Kushner senior advisor to the
President of the United States
but someone that the White House
coronavirus task force directed to work
with FEMA on supply chain issues and in
recent weeks he's been leading a working
group in conjunction with FEMA that
literally has identified millions of
medical supplies around the nation and
around the world and we're grateful for
his efforts and his leadership finally
you'll hear from Peter Navarro who will
explain the action the president took
today using the defense production act
but as you hear details today about
medical supplies that have been
distributed those that have been
purchased those that were making
available ventilators distributed to
hospitals and those that are available
let me just remind every American that
you can make a difference in ensuring
that every patient has the treatment
that they deserve every healthcare
provider every doctor and nurse and
nurses assistant has the protective gear
to provide the care that you would want
your family to have by putting into
practice the president's 30 days to slow
the spread I mean we we want you to take
to heart the president's Korona boilers
guidelines for America first to protect
your own health to protect the health of
your family to protect the health of
your community we know so many people
are asymptomatic and people that
literally don't know they have the
corona virus but have the ability to
infect others we want you to put these
guidelines into practice social
distancing using a drive-through at a
restaurant washing your hands on a
regular basis but as we focus today on
supplies make no mistake about it every
American can make sure that our health
care workers and more importantly
Americans that are struggling with
coronavirus have the equipment to
support their treatment by putting these
principles into practice because the
fewer Americans that contract the corona
virus the fewer Americans will have to
enter our healthcare system and that
will continue to preserve the capacity
in our health care economy so we we
thank millions of Americans who
responded in the first two days of
30 days to slow the spread and I'm just
absolutely confident that in the days
ahead
every Americans gonna do their part for
your health your family's health the
health of your community and to ensure
the strength and vitality of the
greatest healthcare system in the world
with that let me introduce a Jared
Kushner to speak about the work that
he's been doing working with FEMA on
ensuring a strong supply chain to meet
this moment Jared thank you mr. vice
president and thank you for your great
leadership on the task force and thank
you to dr. Burks and dr. Fauci as well
it's been honor working with you these
past few weeks when the Vice President
first asked me to help on the task force
with different tasks I asked the
president what he expected from the task
force and how I can best serve him and
the task force what the president asked
is that all of the recommendations that
we make be based on data he wanted us to
be very rigorous to make sure that we
were studying the data collecting data a
lot of things in this country were
happening very quickly and we want to
make sure that we were trying to keep
updating our models and making sure that
we were making informed decisions and
informed recommendations to him based on
the data that we were able to collect
and put together the president wants to
make sure that we had the best people
doing the best jobs and making sure that
we had the right people focused on all
the things that needed to happen to make
sure that we can deliver in these
unusual times for the American people
the president also instructed me to make
sure that I break down every barrier
needed to make sure that the teams can
succeed this is a an effort where the
government is doing things that the
government doesn't normally do where
we're stretching we're acting very
quickly and the president wants to make
sure that the White House is fully
behind the different people running the
different lines of effort to make sure
that we get everything done in a speed
that the president demands the president
also wanted us to make sure we think
outside the box make sure we're finding
all the best thinkers in the country
making sure we're getting all the best
ideas and that we're doing everything
possible to make sure that we can keep
Americans safe and make sure we bring a
quick end to this and the best way
possible and balance all the different
aspects that need to be thought of while
we do this this truly is a historic
challenge we have not seen something
like this in a very very long
time but I am very confident that by
bringing innovative solutions to these
hard problems we will make progress
today we are briefing the president
earlier he asked me to come out and talk
a little bit about what we've been doing
on the supply chain Task Force which
Admiral plug check has been leading and
and what he's been very impressed by is
the way that we've been resourceful to
find product all over the world all over
the country and we are finding ways to
solve the different problems the
president's been very very hands-on in
this he's really instructed us to leave
no stone unturned just this morning very
early this morning I got a call from the
president he told me he was hearing from
friends of his in New York that the New
York public hospital system was running
low on critical supply he instructed me
this morning I called dr. Katz who runs
the system asked him which supply was
the most supply he was nervous about he
told me was the n95 masks
I asked what his daily burn was and I
basically got that number called up
Admiral bluff check made sure we had the
inventory we went to the president today
and earlier today the president called
Mayor DeBlasio to inform him that we
were going to send a month of supply to
the New York public hospital system to
make sure that the workers on the front
line can rest assure that they have the
n95 masks that they need to get through
the next month we'll be doing similar
things with all the different public
hospitals that are in the hotspot zones
and making sure that we're constantly in
communications with the local
communities one thing I will say just
based on data is that we've been getting
a lot of data from different governors
and from different mayor's and from
different cities one thing I've seen
FEMA do very very well over the last
week or so is now we're getting
real-time data from a lot of cities
people who have requests for different
products and supplies a lot of them are
doing it based on projections which are
not the realistic projected projections
the projections change everyday as we
see the cases as we see the impacts of
the stops of spread effort that this
task force recommended and the president
has been pushing forward so I do think
that we'll see that hopefully there'll
be impact of that and the task force has
been working very hard through the FEMA
group with Admiral Apple of check to
make sure that we're getting the
supplies to people before they run out
and making sure that we're doing it in a
proper way I'd like to just introduce
Admiral
check who before coming to this I guess
still is he's the vice director for
logistics for the Joint Staff I got a
call from one of the senators saying
well why don't you put a great military
person in charge of the logistics in the
supply chain and the defense production
act and I said well the president
already did that this is the best man
that we have in the country for supplies
and logistics I joined the task force 13
days ago over at FEMA and he's built a
team really at the direction of the vice
president that includes people from FEMA
OMB the FDA HHS the White House and from
everywhere else and what they've done
over the last 13 days has been really
extraordinary we've done things that the
government has never done before quicker
than they've ever done it before and
what we're seeing now is we found a lot
of supplies in the country we've been
distributing them where we anticipate
there will be needs and also trying to
make sure that we're hitting places
where there are needs so I can tell you
the people in the in the task force
they're working day and night you've got
a lot of people in the government we
recognize the challenge that America
faces right now we we know what a lot of
the people on the frontlines are facing
the fear that they have that they want
to have the supplies they need and our
goal is to work as hard as we can to
make sure that we don't let them down so
I just want to thank everybody and with
that I'll introduce Admiral club Jack
who's doing an amazing job Thank You mr.
president today I'm gonna cover a couple
items a couple of five things first
thing I'm going to talk about is
resources pushed out from the federal
government then I'm gonna talk about
there's this air bridge which you may
have heard about we talk about data as
you said we're mr. Kushner absolutely
right
we're trying to be data-driven and I'm
gonna talk a little bit about how we're
trying to expand the dust robles year to
meet this challenge so the first thing I
want to talk about is surgical masks so
we've all quickly stated numbers here so
these I'm about to go through several
different slides to give you just scale
and magnitude of federal resources that
have been plied at the problem so 27
point 1 million
surgical masks pushed out to state state
governments for n95 masks nineteen point
five million and ninety-five masks and
so if I was if I was in a local hospital
that was running short
I would I would look upward because the
federal government has pushed out
resources so for protective gloves
twenty two point four million twenty two
point four point four million pairs of
protective gloves for face shields 5.2
million face shields for ventilators we
have pushed to to the States
more than seven thousand six hundred
ventilators and I think as I was coming
over here that numbers changed slightly
I think it's now seven thousand six
hundred and forty given to these states
to the paradigm of these states so we
wanted you to have some numbers now as
we've indicated we have ventilators in
the national stockpile we pushed
ventilators out we're holding
ventilators to put to the point the need
but we're also buying ventilators asking
the industrial base who produces
approximately prior to kovat
approximately thirty thousand
ventilators a year we are going to over
the next several months by the end of
June work to acquire a hundred thousand
and so one of the one of the tools that
we're gonna I can anticipate needing
we've already executed is all of those
vendors that we're buying them from will
need potentially will need help in their
supply chains with their suppliers we
might rate orders we might help them get
ahead of others in that endeavor so I
think mr. Navarro is going to talk a
little bit
or that later so let me talk about the
air bridge so it not normally takes
approximately thirty seven days to get
from overseas the product load it get
into the United States and distribute it
that's about thirty seven days so to
prime the pump so to speak we have lined
on an air bridge to get product here
faster working with our major suppliers
as they have as they work to fill orders
to get more to health care workers now
we are working to align transportation
to product and one of the things we're
also doing is the team that works for me
or scouring the globe in finding pockets
of personal protective equipment that
might not otherwise be in the u.s.
hospital supply chain that is also going
on these flights six completed and a
number scheduled twenty eight twenty
eight flights scheduled here in the near
future we are working towards some days
we'll have one flight some days there
might be two flights multiple flights
over the next coming days these 28 or as
far as I can see out a couple of weeks
again matching product to flights to
create volume in the supply chain here
faster than the thirty seven days I'm
just gonna leave that up as I talked
about a few other items so let's talk
about New York City and the public
health hospitals I believe it's there
called New York City Health and
Hospitals president directed as I speak
there are pallets being formed truck
being loaded I gave a an address in New
York City here
an hour or two ago and one of our
distributors is making that happen and
that delivery will happen tomorrow on
the data front this is almost
unprecedent this is a commercial supply
chain with six to seven major
distributors of health equipment we
brought them all in and we said we we
need to make informed decisions and we
are going to help make informed
allocation decisions so within the
matter of days feeding from their
business systems their enterprise
resource like systems I brought on board
a tool a supply chain tower that the DoD
was using to manage a supply chain for a
very complex weapon system their data
goes into adenylate we have a tool to be
able to use their data and see it I can
tell what product is coming in what
their orders are what they're filling
what they're not filling and see the
volume in the supply chain and
understand what they're doing down to
the county level we're working to get it
potentially down to the hospital level
so this two hundred and some-odd n95
respirators we took a look in there in
the in the supply chain we said we we
can't we have the volume to go do that I
called the distributor and they're
making they're making that happen
we anticipate as the hot spots around
the country we anticipate these vendors
at our direction helping them allocate
product to the right place at the right
time so if I talk finally about
expanding the industrial base so the
vice president who is at Walmart the
other day who told them I want to get in
this game how do I do that so I got the
call
we provided them specifications you know
Walmart is gonna have used their
suppliers to cut fabric make gowns so
product but that's not always the case
we have lots of folks that want to help
believe you will see in the coming days
the use of the defense production act in
creative ways to help people that are
not doing this today to do it we have
essentially leads the number yesterday
was 210 believers but probably grew
today that we are working with to find
how each one of those might need help to
get in the game that's not in the game
to increase the throughput through the
through the healthcare market again the
president gave me one task get more to
our health care workers now and I took
that to heart because I have not that I
don't need that from the president that
direction to move out but I I have
family in New York my sister's a nurse
practitioner in a Westchester hospital
and my niece is a nurse on a Long Island
Hospital and I have other health care
professionals in the family so I have
skin in this game the president asked me
to get more of the health care workers
I'm gonna get more to health care
workers the 200,000 is going out it'll
be it'll be delivered tomorrow what what
Jared announced what the Admiral just
unpacked is that pallets are being
loaded right now to send 200,000 in 95
hours mass to New York City to the
public health hospital so to the public
health warehouse in New York City all
the health care workers help is on the
way on the tools and the data you have
available to you where is the log jam
where has
then have you identified that say all
this when we have millions more PPE is
going out the door as you all know the
frontline unnumbered you can't you can't
you this way we put up a lot of numbers
ayuk said that if you're not a you're in
a hospital and you're not seeing PPE I
would look up to the state level first
and the reason for that is because
according to governor's and also by the
fact that we haven't seen any numbers up
there about what is going to the private
sector can you tell us what percentage
of the supplies on these large cargo
planes are going to private companies
versus FEMA versus the state commission
percent so this product that we're
moving is primarily commercial product
that would enter the commercial system
and be distributed through financial
business transactions between hospitals
and these distributors to clarify that
that explains why states say they're
bidding like they're on eBay because the
supplies are going to the private sector
and then they have to go there to get
this much so that's normally how things
that's normally how things work right so
I'm not here to disrupt a a supply chain
say look these these six distributors
six seven they have six to seven hundred
warehouses they have trucks to go to the
hospital door every day we're bringing
product in they're filling orders for
hospitals nursing homes like normal
I'm putting volume into that system I
would say that that we have the data now
last so we put together this data
element over the last you know what 13
days get the people in look at the
problem build this I am now seeing truth
about what's in the supply chain and I
would say that
there's been some abnormal behavior okay
House Oversight Committee Democrats say
the FEMA officials told them that the
ventilators the government is ordered
won't be ready until June which is well
after the expected peak will the defense
production act memo signed today do
anything to speed that up
yes sir will mr. Navarro we'll talk
about that we're online
to receive several thousand ventilators
in the month of April and several
thousand more ventilators in the month
of May ramping up to a big number in
June again going from you know an
industry that produces about 30 annual
we marry up we're marrying up where CDC
where the demand for kovat is - what's
in this commercial system we're
providing that to these - the commercial
system and we are making allocations to
those most pressing need 13 days we now
have the data we now can make informed
decisions and so all of the I need I
need I need I now know the volume that
has been happening and needs to be happy
as well you talk about though you
alluded to the fact there is possibly
some shady business going on that the
product is here in the United States and
coming here yes and it is coming here
it's coming from China it's in wort
warehouses it's being made here in the
United States it's in warehouses but
it's going to the highest bidder so what
can be done to keep those products here
in the United States not go overseas
where companies are making a lot of
money
and and distributed to the most critical
places here in the US I would love to
hear from that being done because
doctors I've talked questions let me let
me give you the the bigger view of the
DPA will directly address that what we
have essentially is a nation at war we
have a wartime president standing behind
me the defense production act is one of
the most powerful weapons this
administration can use to fight the
invisible enemy of the virus when I
spoke with you last week I explained the
three points of the compass DPA can be
used to hit the the first one is
mobilization of the industrial base this
can involve things like repurposing from
say a distiller like Pernod Ricard from
liquor to hand sanitiser it can also
involve expansion of production which is
having Honeywell which makes n95 masks
open a new factory in Smithfield Rhode
Island with respect to the second point
of the compass allocation of resources
we have two issues there if you look at
the manufacturer itself
what you want to make sure is that the
supply chain which can go seven tiers
deep has enough components in that
supply chain so we can actually make
what we need and then once it's made you
also want to make sure that it goes to
the right right people and then the
third point of the compass which which
addresses what you're talking about is
is basically busting I call it hoarding
of critical or threatened material so
let me walk through what what the
president did today in terms of a strong
action what we've done the DPA across
those three points the first order
president Trump sign was was vigorous
Swift it was the GM order which directed
GM to make ventilators in Kokomo Indiana
in Trump time which is to say as fast as
possible as the president mentioned he'd
spoke to Mary Barra today the CEO of GM
that is moving forward at the same time
as the Ford project is moving forward in
Ross and Ville Michigan and I've issued
a challenge to those two companies out
of Ford versus Ferrari this is Ford
versus
let's see who gets those ventilators out
first now the second point of the
compass which these two orders addressed
today is this allocation of resource
issues the ventilator companies
themselves express concern that in this
rush to build ventilators there would be
pressure on that supply chain so what
day they requested that we do and the
president do is to use the DPA to give
this gentlemen here is when the
strongest gentleman in the world in
terms of applying things is to give him
the ability to prioritize that supply
chain for those ventilator manufacturers
and he will do things like give them
what's called a do rating in the defense
procurement which will allow them to get
what they need now the second order
which the President signed today has to
do with the other part of the equation
which is once they make this stuff okay
where it does it go to the right right
folks and this is a three M order and
and to be frank over the last several
days we've had some issues making sure
that all of the the production that 3m
does around the world enough of it is
coming back here to the right places so
what's gonna happen with the signing to
that order and Trump time is we're gonna
resolve that issue with 3m probably by
tomorrow close of business because we
can't afford to lose days or hours even
minutes in this crisis now the third
part of the compass the third point
there if this gets to the hoarding issue
the president stood up here with with
he's the commander-in-chief but we have
a sheriff in town
- Attorney General bar he stood up here
with the Jena tourney general bar and
Bill Bar said I'm gonna go out and bust
him and guess what three days ago
DOJ went into a warehouse in Jersey
grabbed PPE and the beauty of that the
beauty of that we wasn't only seized but
within hours it was turned around and
given to health care professionals in
New York and New Jersey that's a
beautiful thing that's a beautiful case
of using
the EPA now what's going to happen
tomorrow is presidents gonna sign
another order which is in the works
this is interesting there is a black
market springing up which you have
described where we're having people bid
against each other brokers come in
they're bidding and bidding on all this
different PPE it's driving the price up
and guess what you know where it's going
the domestic sources here are being
exported
when President crumb heard about that he
said that's not going to happen on
anymore under my watch so tomorrow we're
bringing that order and what's going to
do is it's going to empower Customs and
Border Protection with the help of
people like the post office and Express
Mail consigners like UPS to basically a
deal with that issue so we are going to
crack down unmercifully and I would say
to the the hoarders out there the
brokers are trying to make money off of
the misery of people in this country
around the world that's got to stop but
you've got inventory what you need to do
is pick up a phone and not call somebody
out in around the world you call FEMA
and say we got some stuff we'll give it
to you at a fair price and be done with
that because that stuff has absolutely
got to stop so that's that's yeah so
that's that's what we're going to be
looking for and when we hear cases like
this we're going to aggressively issue
order after order to crack down on it
now before this is not my role to take a
bunch of questions but let me tell you
one other thing before I leave the
podium it's a story which I'd love to
share with you today because this again
illustrates one of the key principles of
this president in this vice-president
which is the weds the full force of the
federal government with the full power
of private enterprise and just two days
ago we at the White House got an urgent
SOS from the Chief of Police of the New
York Police Department and they are in a
situation now because of the strain on
their resources where personnel such as
their homicide detectives were having to
go on into houses and deal with with
Cova issues without the protective gear
now the beauty
of this president is because of his
leadership we were able to solve that
problem in two phone calls two phone
calls the first one went to Phoebe
novakovic the General Dynamics Phoebe
can you call Tom Kennedy at Raytheon I
need you guys to basically scoop up all
that I've exude she can find any gloves
you can this president under his
leadership and that voluntary efforts
and the pride and patriotism he talked
about earlier that we had 4,000 tiebacks
suits delivered to the New York PD
within 16 hours that's that's a new
record in Trump time at the same time a
second phone call was made to Terra
angle at Pernod Ricard and Laura Lane at
UPS they were on the same phone call he
said Tarrant Lord we got this issue they
need hand sanitizer literally within two
hours we had 50 gallon drums 6,000
gallons a hand sanitizer on a UPS truck
heading up to the NYPD and it probably
arrived today with a promise from Pernod
that they will continue to supply the
NYPD throughout the course of this
crisis so this this is a beautiful thing
that America is rallying to we are
becoming a stronger more united nation
and I couldn't be more proud of this
president this administration these guys
up here we're doing a heck of a job
organizing the supply chain and my
promise to you is that the president is
going to use that DPA to make sure that
the American people really are health
care professionals get the PPE the
medicines everything we need so let me
let me stop there I don't think it's my
place here to field a bunch of questions
one of the one of the things that this
crisis has taught us or is that we are
dangerously over dependent
on a global supply chain for our
medicines like penicillin our medical
supplies like masks and our medical
equipment like ventilators we have right
now as we speak
over 50 countries have already imposed
some forms of export restrictions in
their country against the rest of the
world and what we've what we're learning
from that is that no matter how many
treaties you have no matter how many
alliances no matter how many phone calls
when push comes to shove you run the
risk as a nation of not having what you
need and if there's any vindication of
the president's by American secure
borders and a strong manufacturing base
philosophy strategy and belief it is
this crisis because it underscores
everything that we see there so the bite
American order which which is going
through process would do do couple
things it would simply say not during
this crisis because we don't want to
disrupt anything I want to be really
clear about that but going forward after
this is over the VA DoD HHS and this
government buys American four essential
medicines or medical countermeasures and
the medical supplies and equipment we
need at the same time it will deregulate
so we can get the FDA and EPA to
facilitate domestic manufacturing and
then innovate because the key here the
key here is having advanced
manufacturing on US soil that can
leapfrog other countries so we don't
have to worry about competing against
cheap sweatshop labor relaxed
environmental regulations different tax
regimes and the massive subsidies of
foreign governments who are actually
directly attacking our industrial base
so be patient with that sir it's it the
other priorities we have right now are
the dpa and what what the task force is
doing but if we learn anything from this
crisis it should be never again never
again should we have to depend on the
rest of the world for our essential
medicines and countermeasures and by the
way we've cut them out also to be honest
we've stopped orders going from certain
places and in a couple of places like we
had a big order going to Italy on the
important outfits and some ventilators
and it was going to Italy they made the
order a long time ago and I said you got
to let it go they've had an order and I
could have cut it under the Act I could
have cut it I said nope can't do that
you got to let it go you know they have
big problems we had an order going to
Spain and I said let it go I could have
stopped it I said let it go we're gonna
be fine I said let it go so it works
that way also one other thing that's to
your question often times and we've told
this to the governor's mic we've been
very strong in this have if you think
there's bidding between federal
government and state let us know and
we'll drop out immediately or you drop
out and we lower the price know if we're
bidding against each other I said find
out who it is and usually they know
everyone knows and we're notified and we
get notified and will either drop out or
they'll drop out but we have another
problem there 151 countries out there
beyond the states there are a hundred
and fifty-one countries that have this
problem and they're ordering too it's
really a mess now in a little while
the hardest thing together the
ventilators because they're you know it
takes a while to build them and we have
a lot we have thousands of them being
built right now in a little while
they'll be worth about $5 but right now
they're very valuable and we're gonna
have a lot of them being shipped in fact
that's why General Motors called up
before Mary that's why others called up
two days ago they called up that they're
all in production and they'll start
they're starting to arrive in a week and
a half but there'll be a time when we're
gonna build stockpiles by the way the
states should have been building their
stockpile we have almost 10,000 and our
stockpile and we've been building and
we've been supplying it but the states
should be building we're a backup we're
not an ordering clerk we're a backup and
we've done an unbelievable job like for
instance who ever heard of a governor
calling up sir can you build us a
hospital of 2005
and we built it can you build us four
medical centers we built it can you
deliver a ship the hospital ship with a
thousand rooms and we did it and we did
it in Los Angeles - we've been an
unbelievable job these people and so and
thousands of people behind them but
we're back up ideally those hospitals
would have had all this equipment
ideally those states should have had all
this equipment and I think they will the
next time you know you heard the case
where thousands of ventilators could
have been had at a very inexpensive
price three years ago and a certain
state decided not to exercise that right
because they wanted to build a road or
they wanted to build something else
because it's big money you're talking
about I think it was a billion dollars
but you're talking about a lot of money
for something that may never happen
because normally on a ventilator other
than a pandemic or an epidemic you
wouldn't you you wouldn't need anything
like this hospitals have three
ventilators big hospitals and they get
by with it and now they want thousands I
mean they want thousands of ventilators
you call up a governor and they'll say
sir could you send us 40,000 ventilate
somebody who's ever heard of a thing
like this so they've done some job let
me just tell you when secretary minuchin
spoke they want you to call not calm but
sba.gov okay for the application and for
information okay so it's s be a small
business sba.gov okay if you don't mind
yeah let's go mr. president I want to
follow up from a question yesterday
regarding her administration's denial
the expansion of Obama care special
enrollment period in the wake of this
pandemic in your own words BP peds gave
a five-minute non answer but people
facing this pandemic illness and even
worse most experts say that having
healthcare is critical to our nation's
health and financial well-being can you
assure Americans tonight that you will
reopen Obama care marketplace ability
may can be covered in this time of
combine well we're doing better than you
you know I understand the question and
we're doing better than that we're going
to try and get a cash payment to the
people and we're working out the
mechanics of that with legislature so
we're going to try and get them a cash
payment because just opening it up
doesn't help as much so we're gonna work
it out so we're going to try and get for
that certain group of people it's a
certain group of people a cash payment
what happens though when they have to
work that out what they should do is
they should have loaned before this
pandemic arrived they should have been
on the open market just buying there was
no competition you could have made a
great price the states have to stock up
it's like one of those things they
waited if they didn't want to spend the
money because they thought this would
never happen and their shelves in some
cases were bare and by the way in some
cases they weren't they were beautifully
serviced they did a good job but in some
cases their shelves were bare so the
best thing they can do is when times
become normalized and they will
hopefully soon and actually you're gonna
have a lot of excess material because so
much is being done right now in terms of
protective gear protective outfits
a lots being done it's gonna be within
six months it's going to be sold for the
right price they go to stack up for the
next time but we are doing that and the
admiral's done a fantastic job I Senator
Schumer wrote a letter today and he says
you should put a military manager I said
well Chuck if you knew a little bit more
we have one of the most highly respected
people in the military the Admiral this
is what he does to very professionally
and he's in charge but Chuck didn't know
that okay Jeff
you tweeted this morning about your call
with Saudi Arabians NBS we've had some
people say that the figures that you
cited between ten thousand ten million
and fifteen million barrels per day is
not what they're agreeing to can you be
more specific about I don't know what
they're going to life I think they might
agree to more than that look Russia are
you that sir Russia yeah we did say that
actually Russia talked about ten million
barrels Russia and Saudi Arabia are
fighting over this and as everybody
knows it's you know really killing an
industry hurting Russia badly hurting
Saudi Arabia badly I said this is an
easy one it should be an easy one and it
may be ten and it may be more than that
I was actually told it may be ten as I
told somebody before it may be ten and
it may be more than that
maybe it's fifteen maybe it goes up to
fifteen could be as high as fifteen and
you know there's a tremendous oversupply
right now that industry was it was over
supplied before the virus and where the
virus came along they lost thirty five
forty percent of the world and there's
an unbelievable you can't get a ship now
every ship is loaded to the gills
sitting out someplace in the ocean
there's storage tanks they're not even
ships the storage tanks so it would be
great for Russia it would be great for
Saudi Arabia I hope they make that deal
but that's what they told me they said
they said it's they swell I think I
think it'll be hopefully soon I think
hopefully they'll announce something
soon now Kennedy will be broken can
something happen where it doesn't happen
I guess in which case there's another
alternative but I'd rather not see that
other alternative I hope they can make a
deal they both want I think they both
want to make a deal and they're both
smart they love their countries they
want to make a deal it's good but it's
also good for the world if they do
because you save an industry payments
I'm gonna let Mike because we went over
this very specifically I'll let you talk
about it Mike because you responded less
than right Thank You mr. president
as I said yesterday the presidents put a
priority on ensuring that no American
has to worry about the cost of
coronavirus testing and we've been
working every day to make sure that
Americans don't have to worry about the
cost of treatment and at this point the
White House coronavirus task force is
working on a proposal for the president
to use some of the 100 billion dollars
that we're making available to hospitals
to compensate the hospitals directly for
any coronavirus treatment that they
provide to uninsured Americans we're
working out the details of that the
president will make a final decision
tomorrow we expect an announcement but
the president's made it very clear we
don't want any American to worry about
the cost of getting a test or the cost
of getting treatment and we've expanded
coverage through Medicaid we've expanded
coverage through Medicare health
insurance companies around the country
including Blue Cross and just today
announced that all of their members will
be waiving all co-payments on
coronavirus treatment before the some 30
odd million uninsured Americans the
president has directed the coronavirus
task force who find a way to make sure
that they know we will find a way to pay
for your coronavirus treatment and the
president will be addressing that and
announcing that tomorrow clarification
yesterday you said that you spoke to
Florida Governor Ron de santis before he
issued his stay home order did you
advise him to issue that order no but I
talked to him about it
and he wants to do what's right for the
people of Florida he's been a great
governor you could see that just by his
popularity which is extraordinary we're
proud of him he's done a fantastic job
and he made the decision but we spoke
before he made this decision yes also
said that he is considering putting
people who were suspected of having
Crona virus or who have tested positive
for it in isolation
so yeah that consultant I haven't heard
that Thank You mr. president
evany mountains from the new york post a
few hours ago matt de Blasio the mayor
of New York said that New Yorkers
leaving their homes to wear masks they
also might wear masks when they're with
other people are you considering that
kind of recommendation on a federal
level and if you are how would you
prevent a Russian and 95 well I think
they're going to be coming out with
regulations on that and if people want
to abide by them frankly I don't think
you could I don't think they'll be
mandatory because some people don't want
to do that but if people want it as an
example in the mix if people wanted to
wear them they can if people wanted to
use scarves which they have many people
have them they can in many cases the
scarf is better it's thicker I mean you
can if you depending on the material
it's thicker but they can do that if
they want now a recommendations coming
out we'll see what that recommendation
is but but I will say this they can
pretty much decide for themselves the
w-h-o I'm even the Surgeon General have
talked about various studies that show
that masks in addition to maybe not even
being helpful to protecting people may
actually increase the rates of illness
because people touch the masks and they
touch themselves can you talk a little
bit about the edge maybe I will attack
you first and you might mention that
other point Joseph thank you so I hope
you got from the conference today that
we're triangulating data that we know
from the case numbers the testing
numbers the supply chain numbers to
create an integrated picture so that we
can really support hospitals in their
needs and I think that level of
granularity is really critical secondly
I just want to make the point that we
really applaud the governor's that are
looking at a whole of state or a whole
of Metro approach and what do I mean by
that
the United States going into this had
about a hundred and sixty thousand
ventilators across the United
States and another 60 to 70 thousand
anesthesia machines that's about five
times what most of the European
countries have but it's a matter of
distribution to need and I really
applaud the governor's that are bringing
together their public hospitals with
therefore more private hospitals and
their visibility across their state
because what we tried to talk about
yesterday is every state every county is
different that's why we're looking at it
at that level of granularity and as we
move through this epidemic the needs
need to be very tailored to those
counties and frankly those hospitals I
mean there is a reason why the President
and mr. Kushner have been very much
involved in finding out what the public
hospitals need why is that because the
public hospitals sometimes have the
weakest supply chain because they're
often sometimes not as attractive to
private sector distributors or they may
be too busy caring for the needs of
patients to be really on top of their
order forms and their supply chains so
really listening to the community that's
at the front of this fight and getting
feedback from those specific communities
no matter where they are and listening
to the frontline health care workers
because it's their reality that is
important to all of us
whether you're the mayor or the governor
or the federal government and if they
are saying they need something we have
to work together to supply that and so
that's what you're seeing with this
triangulation every county will move
through this differently and that allows
us to move around these vital issues
that protect the frontline health care
workers and protect the patients through
the ventilators to make sure that the
supply chain is aligned with the need as
it happens now you have to have very
good data in order to be willing to work
in that level of granularity and that's
what we've been working on to really
develop that level of granularity to
ensure that so I just wanted to say one
other thing about testing I'm just to
give you the bottom line data of what
we're seeing
we appreciate the groups who are
reporting not everyone is
reporting yet and this is part of us
trying to understand at a very granular
level we do have two states that do have
35% positives and that's New York and
New Jersey
so that confirms very clearly that
that's a very clear and important hot
zone Louisiana though has 26 percent of
their tests are positive Michigan
Connecticut Indiana Georgia Illinois so
that should tell you where the next hot
spots are coming are at 15% cus positive
and then Colorado DC Rhode Island and
Massachusetts are at 13% there's a
significant number of states still under
10% every one that I didn't discuss
California and Washington remains steady
at an 8% rate so what we're seeing
finally is testing improving more
testing being done still a high level of
negatives in states without hot spots
allowing them to do more of this
surveillance and containment and then
prioritizing this new rapid test kit to
those areas that may not have the same
amount of access to the Indian Health
Services and to the public health
institutions and the public Houston
State labs so that they can use that and
start forward leaning into surveillance
now we know that our people waiting for
tests and they're waiting for tests
because when these areas became very
when they got on to the logarithmic
curve we prioritize people whose
decisions where the test decision would
make it critical for their care and so
we put prioritized hospitals and we
prioritize nurses and doctors and
frontline workers so that means if you
went through a drive-through or you went
through your doctor you could have that
to law that delay so the mass so what I
tried to give you is how we're using
data in a very granular way and so there
are there's experiential data when you
look at communities that have often time
utilized mass in general for personal
protection from when they particularly
are themselves sick and have used their
masks and
like and we've looked at the rate of
this kovin 19 in those populations and
then we're looking at the scientific
evidence to bring those two pieces
together let me just say one thing
though the most important thing is the
social distancing and washing your hands
and we don't want people to get an
artificial sense of protection because
they're behind a mask because if they're
touching things
remember your eyes are not in the mass
so if you're touching things and then
touching your eyes you're exposing
yourself in the same way so we don't
want people to feel like oh I'm wearing
a mask I'm protected and I'm protecting
others you may be protecting others but
don't get a false sense of security that
that mask is protecting you exclusively
from getting infected because there are
other ways that you can get infected
because the number of asymptomatic and
mild cases that are out there and so
this worries us and that's why the
debate is continuing about the mask
because we don't want when we're trying
to send a signal that every single
person in this country needs to stay six
feet away from everybody that needs to
be washing their hands constantly and
know where their hands are to send a
signal that we think a mask is
equivalent to those pieces so in the
when the advisory comes out it will be
an additive piece if it comes out rather
than saying this is a substitute for and
we want to make sure everybody
understands it is not a substitute for
the presidential guidelines that have
already gone out and to be vapp salutely
clear about that
evidence we're seeing the experts are
saying that my number of these tests
could be producing false false negatives
so I've got Roshan abacus but as many as
one in three tests might be providing
false negative maybe that would almost
be impossible without having 35 percent
positives you if that was true you would
have a hundred percent positive or
sixty-six percent positive so what I can
tell you is the number of positive tests
is tracking very closely with the number
of cases diagnosed so I don't I will
look into that I look at the Roshan
Abbot numbers every night they're
trending exactly in the same way and
that's important when you're validating
data to really validate does this same
sight other words I'm looking between
testing sites to see are there
consistencies is there an anomaly to
make sure for what you just very
specifically asked so I will go back and
look at it more carefully I haven't seen
that kind of anomaly this is the same
platform as being used across the
country and that's a range from what I
reported 3% positivity up to 35%
positivity and that range reflects also
what we're seeing with the hotspots and
the number of cases and frankly I mean
we hate to talk about it but it also
tracks with the hospitalizations
independent of diagnosis and the
mortality that we're seeing so all of
those pieces validate the other white
people might be getting a false sense of
security or that we might not be seeing
all of the
well I'm telling you I'm still missing
50% of the data from reporting I have
660 tests reported in we've done 1.3
million so there is and it could be
those sites so we do need to see the
bill said you need to report we're still
not receiving a hundred percent of the
tests the president sample collection
took one-minute results reported back in
15 minutes I realize you're the
President of the United States but when
will everyone get to take a test that
works that quickly and you get results
that quickly so these are new tests and
we have prioritized the groups that we
think have the least access to testing
now and who do we mean by that we mean
the Indian Health Service they're often
in remote areas rural areas the
governors of the northwestern states
that may not have the advantage of these
high throughput machines that are often
across the East Coast and in high metro
areas Colorado and then across the west
coast so we've prioritized the
presidential 15-minute test to the
Indian Health Services and public health
labs so that they can support nursing
home testing and other areas where we
think surveillance is absolutely key so
at this moment they're prioritized in
that way yes 1200 of them are going out
in that way those tests need to be made
in order from every move yes okay so in
a matter of the moving quickly I'm glad
you asked that because today there's
18,000 of these machines already out
there we're trying to find out exactly
where everyone is because you can see
that gives you amazing flexibility
because if people would allow it to be
loaned to a state that's in a hot spot
or a state where you want to do
additional surveillance 18,000 tests
18,000 machines is a huge amount and it
really gets to your very question about
how we can prioritize what we have at
the same time we're moving out what is
new and so really figuring out
who should those go to how can we ask
communities because these will be in the
community to share those machines into
the community who need the testing now
and I think that's really an incredible
question that really needs to be
answered over the next 24 hours
when clarity about the face covering
guidance you said it's still a point of
debate you said they'll use the phrase
the guidance if it comes out is the
guidance coming out and and what yes in
Windsor consultation advice CDC our top
health experts and we bring forward just
remember it's not a substitute for
everything they were asking people to do
and just do that to everybody out there
across the country when we say no
gatherings of 10 we're looking at we
wanted to be clear if you have a family
of 10 we don't want you to be split up
but we don't expect people to be having
dinner parties cocktail parties I mean I
know you've seen the slope in the United
States versus the slope in Italy and we
have to change that slope we have to
change the logarithmic curve that we're
on we see country after country having
done that what it means in the United
States is not everyone is doing it so
we're only as strong as every community
every county every state every American
following the guidelines to a tee and I
can tell by the curves and as it is
today that not every American is
following it and so this is really a
call to action we see Spain we see Italy
we see France
we see Germany when we see others
beginning to bend their curves we can
bend ours but it means everybody has to
take that same responsibility as
American this is
mr. president got a quick follow-up on
oil please in your conversations with
Russia and Saudi Arabia did you have to
make any concessions to get them to
agree to cut their production like did
you agree to cut US production well we
didn't discuss that they want to do that
that's good for their countries and we
did not discuss that down to fire the
captain of the USS Theodore bells after
he raised red flags about the Cova 19
outbreak on his ship it appears as if
he's being punished for trying to save
the lives of the sailors in his command
but we're gonna wait a little while
because I understand as a news
conference by the Secretary of Defense
about that but you know I don't I don't
agree with that at all
not at all not even a little bit yeah
thank you this morning you said once
again that New York got off to a late
start and they should have pushed harder
but governors and other state leaders
say they rely on the federal government
to assess the situation and how risky it
is and they want to know how would they
have known to start sumo without your
guidance will they have experts and
frankly long after we came out and
talked about it look how would I have
known to cut off China I cut off China
very early and if I didn't we would have
a chart that you wouldn't believe so how
would I know to do that how would I know
to cutoff Europe I could oh if Europe
very early I mean you have to make a
decision people knew that some bad
things were going on and they got off to
a late start and some others got off to
a late start also but we cut off China
if we didn't cut off China we would have
been in some big trouble and we cut it
off and you know what we cut it off way
early go ahead I'm the insurance point
in a separate question that came in from
a colleague who can't be in the room on
the insurance point is they're going to
with the roll call is there going to be
an opportunity
for insurance companies if in fact
hospitals are compensated for
uncompensated care are the insurance
company is going to also get compensated
for its extraordinary expenses that they
may have reduce assuming that cost
though we haven't discussed it but we're
talking to them you know getting them
not to pay co-pays in the case of the
big ones was a tremendous thing that's a
lot of money they gave up but we're
discussing that with the insurance
companies well let you know it'll be
pretty quickly yeah go ahead I have a
question on Japan sir they are expanding
their entry ban to include the United
States are you planning to take any
similar action to ban Japanese nationals
from coming to the US as a result of
this crisis well we're looking at a lot
of things and a lot of different bands
we have more bands than anybody we had
bands when bands weren't fashionable if
you remember right at the beginning of
this administration was for different
reasons
but we've had bands long before people
thought of bands when I did China it had
never been done before I was the first
one to do remember that it had never
according to what I read it all the
papers this had never been done this is
a terrible thing to do and four weeks
later they were all saying were lucky we
did it so we're looking at it no we
heard that and I think it's fine that
they do that they're trying to protect
their country and we have to protect our
country that you know decision should be
left in the hands of governors or if
you're considering and selling the
entire nation stay at home so just today
the Georgia's governor finally issued
stay-at-home water saying that
individuals could have been infected
people before they ever felt bad but we
didn't know that until the last 24 hours
is that ignorance grossie
he's a good governor Brian cap he's a
very good good governor and he has to
make his own decision on that I let the
states I think we're about 85% positive
on that if you look I think it's about
eighty-five percent of the states have
got to stay at home Brian's a great
governor will it's his decision he made
that decision ultimately he decided to
go along with it
and they're doing and they're doing well
and the state's doing well in many
respects yeah go ahead please stay from
Emily good in the day we met the
question in regards to the Russian plane
that landed at JFK with medical supplies
did the United States ask Russia for
this aid or is it just accepting it
we're accepting it was a very nice offer
from President Putin I spoke to him the
other night as I told you and they had
excess medical equipment things and I'll
take it I'll take it I think it's very
nice we've had some from the China
we also helped other countries we like
doing that like I said before if we have
excess stuff we let it go out we let
some go out we're frankly they had
orders for it and I didn't want to stop
orders it was a very nice gesture on
behalf of President Putin and I could
have said no thank you or I could have
said thank you and it was a large plane
of very high-quality medical supplies
and I said I'll take it any further aid
in your honor I think you what have we
asked for it but he was very nice it was
part of the call he suggested he said we
have it it's additional well they have
very big difficulties with this virus
also as you know Russia I thought it was
a very nice gesture on behalf of
President Putin I could have said nota
want it or it could have said I'll take
it and you know what I said I'll take it
except for the range I think they sent
things that we need I take it sure nice
gesture I'm not concerned about Russian
propaganda not even a little bit he
offered a lot of medical high quality
stuff that I accepted and that may save
a lot of lives
I'll take it every day see and you'll
continue to stand with the people of
Iran given the fact they're so hard to
hit with for novaro they're very hard
hit they're very hard in a lot of ways
they're hard they don't hit in with
their economy with their military and
with obviously the virus they're very
hard at would you consider easing
sanctions to allow medical supplies to
get in they haven't even asked us to do
that we know that sanctions hit the
people not the government you know what
they haven't even asked us to do that if
they want to me would love to meet and
we'd love to settle the whole thing out
but I doubt they'll be realistically how
does a person in Tehran pick up the
phone and call you I think they'll love
America
I think the Iranians love America I
think they'd love to be free I think
they'd love to have just some of the
things that we have you know I remember
Iran many years ago friends of mine were
always in Iran they were doing real
estate deals in Iran they were building
beautiful buildings all over Iran
apartment houses it was they were very
successful and then one day that came to
an end but you don't want the people of
a red they remember that it was a long
time ago but not so long ago they
remember it and I'll tell you they love
America they love what we stand for and
we're not looking for chair we're not
looking for government take over
government change you know this country
has been through that many times that
doesn't work people do encourage other
countries to who are maybe concern
remember what I did yeah what I did is
you know I put it out very publicly with
respect to Iran I said if they need help
with respect to the virus we'd love to
said we have the greatest medical
professionals in the world would love to
see are you encouraging perhaps to to
lend their support because there are
many countries that we know encouraging
and discouraging they've been a very
hostile country they made a deal that
President Obama should have never made
it was a short-term deal giving them one
hundred and fifty billion dollars giving
them 1.8 billion dollars in cash green
times do you have a world responsibility
I have a moral responsibility to help
them if they ask if they if they needed
help I would certainly consider
different nation says they need help
well that's up to the United Nations I'm
talking about us and what happens is if
they wanted help because they have a
very big case of virus a very very big
case it one of the worst on earth if you
believe what you're reading and I happen
to believe what I see and what I know
and if they wanted help we'd give them
help you had enacted the DPA on
ventilators and masks are there any
signals from across the country that
might indicate there are other things
besides masks and ventilators that are
slowly rising in terms of meat like hand
sanitizer for instance sure so the first
the first issue that we've been dealing
with was really the ventilators that was
the number one number two and number
three from all the states what we've
been finding is that people have a lot
of these requests based on the models
and what we've been trying to do over at
FEMA is say to the states well if you
would like ventilators we need to see
first look in your states right so for
example in northern Jersey they're going
down to southern Jersey and they're
finding ventilators and trying to
relocate them to where they have their
hot spots the second thing that we've
done is we've asked them to survey for
alternative ventilators dr. Burke spoke
before about the anesthesia machines and
the ability to to convert them to be
ventilators so we're asking people to be
resourceful inside their states before
they come to the federal government the
third thing we've been asking states to
do is to provide what their daily
utilization rates are so everyone's
asking for everything one congressman
got a call from his local hospital
saying I need 250 ventilators and he
said well you don't have a kovat patient
within four counties why do you want 250
ventilators and he says well we just
want to be safe we're very nervous right
now so what you have all over the
country is a lot of people are asking
for things that they don't necessarily
need at the moment and the job of FEMA
and an admiral Bluff jack has been
try to make sure that we're getting the
real data from the cities from the
states that we can make real-time
allocation decisions based on the data
and right now what's happening is a lot
of the different cities and states are
providing FEMA that that information
we're talking to them daily they're
updating that information daily and
that's enabling the federal government
to make much more informed decisions on
where they position ventilators you also
have a situation where in some states
FEMA allocated ventilators to the states
and you have instances where in cities
they're running out but the state still
has a stockpile and the notion of the
federal stockpile was it supposed to be
our stockpile it's not supposed to be
state stockpiles that they then use so
we're encouraging the states to make
sure that they're assessing the needs
they're getting the data from their
local local situations and then trying
to fill it with the supplies that we've
given them the same thing with the masks
so the n95 mask is actually an item that
wasn't used as frequently in the medical
profession before this it was used for
mostly for diseases so speaking to a lot
of the doctors and hospital
administrators they would say they used
actually a very low percentage of the
m95 masks with the president the vice
president were able to do with Congress
was to get the waiver so that you could
expand the pool cuz a lot of vin masks
were used to defer the construction
industries now there's a much bigger
pool of masks in the country there was a
stockpile they distributed that based on
where they anticipated a lot of the need
would go but a lot of that still is
stuck with the states and it hasn't
trickled down to the right places within
the state so I would just encourage you
when you have governor's saying that the
federal government having hasn't given
them what they need I would just urge
you to ask them well have you looked
within your state to make sure that you
haven't been able to find the resources
unlike other countries a lot of the
medical system in America is a private
it's not a it's not a public government
controlled so you have to get the data
from what's in their state look at it in
that way and then make sure that they're
being resourceful in a way to do that
and also ask them what their utilization
percentage is because if one governor is
asking for more ventilators and if the
federal government sends them more than
they need the goal here is not to have
ventilators sitting in a warehouse where
you have another state where you have
people who need them so what we're
trying to do is make informed
data-driven decisions both on
ventilators masts any other supply we
can get to make sure it's going to the
people who need them
I wonder if you could weigh in on the
reports that which I'm sure you are
aware we're unnamed White House
officials have described your role as
being something of running another
shadow task force how do you describe
your role how you how do you describe
the qualifications you bring to the
table yeah I would just say very simply
like the president asked the vice
president to run the task force the vice
president asked me to assist I've been
serving really at the direction of the
vice president he's asked me to get
involved in different projects the vice
president I speak probably sometimes
five ten times a day but everything that
I'm doing is at the direction of the
vice president if some people are
talking to you that means they're
probably not informed as to what's going
on but I can assure you that I'm
speaking with dr. Burks dr. Falchi the
vice president and the president
multiple times a day to make sure that
I'm accomplishing and focusing on the
objectives that the vice president deems
a priority what triggers sending a
ventilator from the national stockpile
to a state in other words how sick does
somebody have to be to get one of these
national ventilators that's not the
issue that works that's not the criteria
you have the states basically putting in
the request and they're giving us their
utilization because their utilization
percentages so it's it's a very simple
formula the states should know how many
ventilators they have in their states
and by the way some governor's you speak
to her senators and they don't know
what's in their state you know some
governor's I'll speak to and they'll
know to the number how many ventilators
they have in their state because that's
the first thing a good manager will do
what a lot of the voters are seeing now
is that when you elect somebody to be a
mayor or governor or president you're
trying to think about who will be a
competent manager during the time of
crisis this is a time of crisis and
you're seeing certain people are better
managers than others so what I would say
is that the way that the federal
government's trying to allocate is
they're trying to make sure hey you have
your data right don't ask us for things
when you know that when you don't know
what you have in your own state just
because you're scared you ask your
medical professionals and they don't
know you have to take inventory of what
you have in your own state and then you
to be able to show that there's a real
need and so we pre-positioned a lot of
things because most governor's off the
bat didn't know what they needed but
FEMA has a joint command with Admiral
Bluff Jack Admiral Joe wah and Pete
Gaynor where every couple hours when
their requests come in they evaluate the
request they all vote on the requests
and then if there is something that they
want to elevate the task force they
bring it to the vice president to make a
recommendation literally tracking
hospitalization cases on a daily basis
interacting with governor's and health
systems and that informs our supply
chain decisions yeah I really I want to
thank the health commissioners and all
of them that have been sending Hospital
data and I think it's really critical
and important to all of us New York City
has been providing information New
Jersey Connecticut Rhode Island and
certainly Louisiana in these hot spots
and that allows us we can see where they
are with the rising number of cases
where they are in their curve what can
be predicted and really ensuring that
people get what they need as they need
it and so I think many of the governor's
now and the health commissioners have
been I had to use 20 I'm into baiting 20
people a day now I have enough for the
next three days if that doubles we're
seeing our hospitalization rates
stabilizing but we still think there
will be this many more in the next days
that's the information that they then
translate into providing as a ventilator
so when you see the ventilator numbers
going out they're going out in one 50s
and 200s because I think early on we
sent a big bolus out and then not all of
them even today have been fully utilized
and so we want to make sure every state
and every hotspot can be reassured that
ventilators are there for them as they
move through the curve and I think to
date we've been able to do that and I
think that's what's important to me is
that people have what they need when
they need it and to date people who have
needed ventilators have been able to get
on vanilla
and I think that's our goal with
governor's and with the mayor's to make
sure that continues to happen but that
means all of us have to work together
and I think that's what's been really
important over the last few weeks is
people are not making generic requests
anymore they're making data-driven
requests because they know precisely
what's happening in their hospitals when
you were up here a little bit ago and
you talked about the curve and what
you're seeing and your concern that
people are not abiding by the social
distancing guidelines and you've seemed
in your voice to be quite concerned
about that um it has the curve changed
enough at this point where that a
hundred and hundred thousand to two
hundred and forty thousand people likely
to die and that shifted upwards at all
no it's just when I look at what so
we're in week two point two in our
guidelines and I guess what I expected
when the president put out guidelines
that said don't go to bars don't be in
groups more than ten people when we said
that now over 16 days ago that was
serious and then you could see what
happened subsequently and you can see
the number of individuals have been
infected since then because the people
were seeing infected today and in
hospitals today were infected after the
guidelines went out so that's what we're
worried about and we're worried about
that we're not we're still in this and
that's why the president extended it for
30 days but we have to get out of this
we have to start seeing this Debra are
you wearing shoes
a few states because many of those
states are 37 yes there are states that
are dead flat but you know every every
what changes the curve is a new Detroit
a new Chicago a new New Orleans a new
Colorado those change the curves because
it all of a sudden spikes with the
number of new cases because you have a
certain projection of new cases and then
a whole nother city comes on top where
they're in their logarithmic phase so
those ones that I talked about that had
test results greater than 13 percent
positive all of those all of those
states are all of those counties are in
logarithmic phase that means there are a
lot of counties that aren't and we are
really we're excited about those
counties that have been testing and
still finding quite flat and hopefully
maybe Sunday or so or sometime this
weekend we can go through all the states
and the curves again so you can see
where you know that California and
Washington are still steady but we're
watching very carefully because we see
that you can go from this to this very
quickly and when this should not be
happening any longer in new places if
people are doing the social distancing
washing their hands not getting together
in large groups more than ten
yes and you have many many Flatliners
and you have a couple that are no no I
don't want to say that no don't tempt a
oh I don't want in fact I want to praise
the states that and I think I want to be
able to call them out and show you their
graph so you can see they've had steady
small cases they're testing and they're
doing a lot of testing and their percent
of test positives are under five percent
I mean we have a whole group of states
who are testing and their positivity
rate is under five percent we know what
it looks like on the logarithmic curve
you're in the thirteen percent then
fifteen percent then twenty six percent
and then two thirty five percent that's
what we're trying to prevent and it's
the metro areas that are absolutely
crucial in this and so if you're in a
metro area all right you're in a small
city please make sure all of your
friends and family are following the
guidelines that's the best thing she can
meet all of them so when you register
while maybe talking about one state and
another state is you know having a hard
time it's and they're closely associated
and by the way the people are doing a
very good job including the people that
live there but when Deborah was talking
about Italy she was talking about the
one and then the other was lower and
then you have mostly states that have
been unbelievable so she wasn't talking
about the average of everything she was
talking about an individual state which
is I think still better than Italy
Italy's having a hard time by the way
Spain is having a hard time Frances
having a hard time but our state's
generally speaking it's like lots of
different countries all over we have
many of those countries are doing a
phenomenal job they're really flat and I
think that's what you
I don't know I don't want to I don't
want to but I thought that's what I
understood she met yep it's not that
though because coronavirus is present in
all 50 states you said before that when
you implored mayors and then governor's
to be serious about this you said once
it shows up mitigation act efforts are
too late so how do you then square that
with this notion that some states are
doing well I mean the virus doesn't
change they stay in better they're not
touching they're not whatever it is
they're not going out there not in
groups and some states are not probably
as good or for whatever reason or they
also live a lot closer you know New York
is very dense and you know California is
pretty dense too and they've got a very
good record going so far we hope it
doesn't spike up but it's very flat we
have states that are doing incredibly
well I mean when I looked at some of
them I looked at some states that I
would have thought maybe wouldn't have
done as well and they're really
flatlined hope they stay that way I hope
but we never mentioned about Italy and
our country she wasn't referring to our
country she was referring to one state
she's encouraging people to do a better
job of following these social distancing
measures that's what I'm understand okay
so my understanding I'm gonna let her
say but I think that everybody would
have to be thrilled with the way most
states are doing thrilled the flatlining
the flatline states states that have
almost no bump I mean I would think then
you have others where for whatever
reason they're higher that's different
but you can't condemn people living in a
flat liner with people living in
something where there's the big bump or
the bigger bump or more akin to Italy
where they have some very unique
problems and all fairness to Italy they
have some very unique problems but if
you'd like to come up and
No why don't I bring you the whole deck
again and we'll divide out the states so
you can see them because you really have
to see each state separately that's why
I started with there are states where
you've heard me talk about how concerned
I was
these are states that before the
guidelines went out or right after the
guidelines went out I mean you can look
at it's on the website if you go to the
health data org
governor's made clarity about closing
their states as far as the social
distancing the washing in my hands the
bars the taking doing takeout and you
can line that up with the presidential
guidelines and not all states when the
presidential guidelines came out
immediately followed the presidential
guidelines not all states did there are
states that also may have gotten many
more seeds from outside communities that
certainly is one of the issues that New
York and New Jersey Connecticut and
Rhode Island are facing the virus came
in from multiple places into those
states it were it was undetected early
on and they have a very logarithmic
curve what I'm saying is even one of
those curves in one County in one city
is one curve too many so I am passionate
about everyone following the guidelines
because of the outlier curves maybe that
was a better way of putting up the
outlier curves in specific counties is
to make sure and that doesn't happen
anywhere else you feel better if every
state did a stay at home or well I think
most of the states have done that I
think if you one death from this is one
death too many I mean I come out of
epidemics and pandemics we know what to
do I know we don't have a vaccine and I
know we don't have a therapeutic but we
know what can be done and others are
doing it and most of the people in the
United States are doing it
it's our communities it's every American
that has to make these changes and I
know they're really hard and I know it's
hard to remember I mean I have to say to
myself every day because I'm around very
important people to like never touch
anything and I'm just like paranoid now
about touching things I'm sure you all
are too
I mean we've gotten to the place where
we don't go to your places on Pebble
Beach we go to the one that's open aired
because I mean you're prying to protect
your reporters I mean I understand that
we're all trying to protect each other
and we all have to adapt to this new
reality that we're in right now and I
believe everybody is trying really hard
and I'm just asking them to try really
really hard for these next 28 days
because they will make a tremendous
difference we see that evidence and so
it's like having a vaccine or a
therapeutic because we know what works
and we're asking everybody to apply what
works and I know it takes amazing
attention to detail because you know
that when you the minute you forget or
do something you're like oh my gosh I
should have never done that and that's
the level of attention it takes many
states have started low and slow and
then they stayed at a good level some
really stayed at a great level some
louisiana's an example it was low and
slow and they were looking great I was
watching it because you know it's kind
of a place people go to with Mardi Gras
which sort of it's an interesting point
because after Mardi Gras it was low and
then all of a sudden it went up very
rapidly and now it's one of our true hot
spots right certain areas of Michigan
Detroit which looked like it was doing
pretty good and then all of a sudden it
went up so you have that too but I'll
tell you what we have states that have
been really incredible in the fact that
they have kept so so low they have not
you haven't seen the bump and I hope you
don't I hope you don't and you have a
couple that for a lot of different
reasons and that's not to blame anybody
but they are at a higher loved
but very few I think ever I mean I may
say I think most people have actually
followed the presidential you can call
them whatever you want I would never use
the word dictates because if I use that
word I would be in such trouble in fact
you put me in trouble just that I even
mentioned the thought of it okay but we
make a recommendation and I think
they've done a good job maybe they
started a little later but maybe there
were also more difficult States but
we've done I think on average really
phenomenally as a country I think we've
done phenomenally because when you
looked at that graph the other day I
don't know if you saw it I assume you
saw it everybody in the world saw it but
you look at all those lines on the
bottom one color after another all
different representing different states
it's all crowded at the bottom and then
you had two that were up but you had I
don't know almost every one of them was
down low very low so there were a lot of
people listening and I just did want to
click because I don't need headlines
tomorrow neither does the country
because I don't want this country
working so hard and then have press that
is in this case maybe misinterpret
something because I might have I might
have when I heard it I was surprised at
first too but I understood what Deborah
meant but I think it's very important
because I think it's very important for
you to be accurate one other thing just
a quick thing so what I found is when
governors call me I mean I think in
every case they've always been so nice
so nice and I've seen them and heard
them say thank you very much you have
done a great job a fantastic job in one
case thank you thank you thank you then
I'll see the governor usually of the
office opposite party in almost all
cases except maybe one but in almost all
cases they're very generous they're very
nice they thank me everything's great
we're doing a great job and then I'll
see them on television and just like a
different person and I realized there
are some people because of politics that
if they say we want a thousand
ventilators and I'll say no Jim I want
to give you five thousand ventilators
they'll say thank you you are the
greatest president that's ever lived
and then I'll see them quoted in a paper
or see them on a show and they'll say
the president didn't come through for me
I'm very disappointed in the president
and we have a lot of that they're very
happy when they talk to me then I see
him but there are some people if they
asked for five hundred of something and
if I gave them five thousand they will
say you'll say how's the president doing
well we don't like the job to my face
they're very nice but then sometimes I
guess they assume I don't watch him or
something but I watched very closely
yeah please wondered if you could
address what the federal government is
doing to protect one that is close
together really I I can't tell you about
age but a lot of young people in prison
some people some states I have not done
that at all but some states are letting
people out of prison some people are
getting out that are very serious
criminals in some states and I don't
like that I don't like it but it's a
city or state thing in certain cases as
you know I think maybe Philadelphia
comes to mind so we'll see you have to
see what what's going on and we don't
like it the people don't like it and
we're looking in to see if I have the
right to stop it in some cases okay six
point six million Americans filed for
unemployment last week we haven't heard
of you talk a lot today about what
they're going through so oh I think it
was just a minute I think it's terrible
so look four weeks ago we had the
greatest economy in the history of the
world the greatest in the world greatest
in the history of the world we had the
most jobs ever in the history of the
United States almost 160 million jobs
right and then one day I get a call from
Deborah it was fantastic and from doctor
foul Chee and he said and she said we
have a problem I said what's the problem
and they said we may have to close it up
I said close what up
they said close up the country I said
what's that all about
and we discussed today and probably not
since 1917 came to that conclusion and
she is a fantastic person the brilliant
person and this is what she knows I said
has it ever been this bad and I think I
can represent that you said no and part
of it it's a contagion it's so
contagious it's like if you sneeze I
probably get it who ever heard of a
thing like that okay and this very
talented reporter is bailing out okay
he's out of here I don't blame you but
it's a very contagious thing and
probably the likes of which we've never
seen in terms of that but 1917 so that's
over a hundred years ago but that was
you know it's been written about many
many times that was a horrible weather
it was 75 or 100 million people I've
heard from 50 to 75 I heard 75 to 100
but it was tens of millions of people
now we have the advantage of
communication this could have been just
as bad I mean here we can read on the
internet we can see what to do we can
have these meetings they can watch on
television which they do a lot of people
are watching a lot of people are
watching and they say gee social
distancing but in 1917 they didn't have
that option you know they didn't know
what to do they just noticed people were
dying all over the place think of it 75
to 100 million people died a lot of
people in this country died I always to
me it's a great it's a great question
how come more people didn't die in this
country and they say it actually started
in this country and went to Europe and
we lost a lot of people but relatively
we lost very few compared to Europe so
this is a terrible thing that happened
and what's happening now with people and
jobs so think of the position I'm in we
have built all together everybody not me
everybody the greatest economy in
history and all of a sudden people come
in that we respect do we know
and here's the thing they were right
everybody questioned it for a while not
everybody but a good portion question
that they said let's keep it open let's
write it if we did that you saw the
other graph and whether it's true or
almost true or maybe not true enough
the number was 2.2 million people would
have died 2.2 million people would have
died in a short period of time
in fact the graph could have been even
shorter I always notice that that
horrible one where it goes high it
actually comes down a little bit faster
it might have been over faster and you
would have lost 2.2 million people so
they come in and they say we have to
close up like on J and I say you know
what that does to this to the fabric of
this country to people that had great
jobs great family no problems with money
their 401 K everything is perfect then
all of a sudden they go from that to
having no job in one day than ever even
thought of it and then you see 6 million
people unemployed unemployment numbers
get released and you see 6 million
people and it's an artificial closing
it's not like we have a massive
recession or worse it's artificial
because we turned it off think of what
we're doing we're saying don't go to
work and we'll pay you everything's the
opposite
it was always go to work and make a lot
of money and do well and the American
dream because of a hidden enemy we're
saying don't go to work and we're going
to pay you look at the money two
trillion dollars and we will probably do
more I think infrastructure would be a
fantastic thing to do you want to get
the restaurants back you give
deductibility you understand what that
is you give deductibility for businesses
where they go and they use the
restaurants the restaurants will be
bigger and better than they were before
you know people don't know a lot of
restaurants closed when they ended
deductibility and then they started
doing well but they had fewer
restaurants but the boom of the
restaurants is when they had
deductibility what corporations could
use them so an entertainment that was a
great thing
but they closed it and then they closed
it again and it wasn't the same but you
want to get him back you do that
infrastructure we borrow our money now
at zero you know if we were paying five
percent four percent three percent it's
a different ballgame we borrow we can
borrow long-term four zero literally
zero you know that because we're
considered the safe investment all over
the world they want money in the United
States that's where they want the money
so I know better than anybody I just I
know what they're going through and it's
horrible but you know what I want to do
I want to be able to get him back fast
when this is over it's gonna be a day
we're gonna celebrate because everyone's
gonna go to work and I think we're gonna
have boom times I think it's gonna be
great
and we've learned a lot we've learned
about borders we've learned about
reliance on other countries we've
learned so much so much that I think we
really have a chance to be bigger and
better and stronger and I think it's
going to come back very quickly but
first we have to defeat this enemy so we
will see you tomorrow thank you very
much